o lado diz pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dark seja muito bem-vindo ser mais um
vídeo e o estrago de que faz na e 7 fred
strecht estamos aqui para jogar a
terceira foquem noite é pessoal não está
em transe muito esta série porque o meu
jogo completamente e depois do jogo fui
pagar do site eu tive que voltar a
explorar para que alguém pessoal jogo e
voltar a baixar para depois continuar a
série foi uma carga de complicações
pessoal mas já que estamos aqui outra
vez eu avancei até a terceira noite
bora lá então voltar aqui com a série y
em força temos na terceira noite faltam
demais que mais três noites têm até a
sexta ou sétima já nem sei mas é pessoal
vamos buscar o que é que a gente está
bem meton fullscreen volume no foco em
máximo o rosto muito factível mas não
interessa nada o cara pega siga ok
pessoal terceira noite 6 faquim de noite
e portas abertas ter as portas abertas
muito calor não quer saber da cal e
alguns de vocês também já me falaram que
por ser um novo animatrónica é verdade
eu ainda não vi imagens dominada por que
não quis falar também
mas pronto inglês vossos comentários
logo à partida já sei o que vai
acontecer né
ok estamos aqui no palhaço eu estou
falando muito porque porque como é que
eu fui e está entre essa pois não vamos
controlar o palhaço porque já sei como
vai saltar em cima porque ele é muito
agressivo neste início
mas eu acho que já consigo escapar deu
porque vocês me disseram para eu usar a
máscara quando por ser cara deu na
televisão mas que isso não acontecia
porque eu estava empolgado então eu não
conseguir fazer mesmo nada pessoal eu
tava sempre para cima mesmo que aconteça
mais cor ou não mas agora eu acho chata
resolvi por isso embora lá ok eu não sei
se vai haver uma voltinha continua a
olhar para eu mas vamos ficar um pouco
mais pessoal pelo menos até à uma da
manhã para garantir lhe que nada
acontece que nós estamos a avançar no
tempo não é quebrar um pouco vago ou não
cooperar ou não isto foi um sinal para
não beber água clara guia tipo
investigar me fazer aqui e um pedaço de
um sinal para não beber água mas pronto
lá ok pedaço está na sala 8 eu sei vai
dizer se ele vai para a sala 4 já
assisti tudo corp
imensos vezes mas como estava o lugar
não deu em nada mas bora lá ok agora já
posso ver agora é pelas fotos é possível
ver a bagunça parece que finalmente o
filho da mãe meu mais rápido na noite
anterior já alguém vai ser para cima e
josé coelho vai avançar para 88 já sei
tudo do core com 82 da manhã
a primeira por cima ou para baixo eu
perco tempo o jogo irão funcionar
imaginem salão 14 e um tempo eu não sei
explicar isso mas o jogo está mais ou
menos feito sim porque eu já tive de
estar ou seja se eu ficar muito tempo
parado na mesma câmara é eu vai passar
mais lentes de câmeras que vão
acontecendo mais rápido mas agora andar
câmera vira o pessoal do mal odeia
câmara as coisas foram acontecendo e
duas da manhã
agora é meu por favor
funcionou funcionou são três da manhã
nas agora usei quando já deve estar aqui
meu eu ficar aqui muito perto de fechar
as portas porque não era preciso mesmo
aqui dentro então eu vou
o que conseguir filho também consegui
meu conseguir conseguir uma resposta
[Música]
amanhã é e apareça aqui tava luz é pinto
táxi josé pinto meu calma tranquila em
breve tem que ter muita atenção que eu
sei qual é o meu
lógico que vão solicitar a subir nem na
tira tira tira tira um pouco mais vai
aparecer agora o que eu acho que
consegui escapar
eu acho que nunca sabe só porque os pais
aparecem a tua cama você passa lá dentro
da oca está tudo tranquilo então susep a
gastar dentro da caixa porque está tudo
tranquilo eu só preciso de palhaço numa
trapalhada agora é o fred vai ser meu
gol de felipe
roma 4 da manhã pessoal só nos faltam
duas foi embora não gosta gosta eo edith
ea máscara eu fiz gosta
[Música]
isso não parece julho rodrigues do cabo
gado meu assim que voltei e voltei
porque preciso ter cuidado com o fred e
mel que o filho da mãe toma quatro da
manhã pessoal são quatro da manhã e só
faltam duas horas meu
agora vamos avançar muito bem tranquilo
tranquilo agora é o próximo e no próximo
o gato alta onde vou tentar aqui perto
que buscam de forma muito banho eu nem
sei como mas thomas o faria mas que tal
mandar tóxico meu isso não podem ficar
em tóxicos não um morro às cinco da
manhã pessoal 5 da foquinha automóvel
precisa agüentar mais um pouco
o canto do sapato
agora só falta a calma
[Música]
a manhã foi bem mais difícil do que
ouviu e vamos lá ver o que vai acontecer
agora é fred olha pra mim como sempre né
e josé coelho neto esta [ __ ] q isto que
isto é o palhaço
nené not assim pra mim mas não age assim
por mim em qualquer lado que um vai lá
pra mim é ficar porque com esta noite 3
temos aqui no ip4 para jogar e não sei
se é fácil já hoje ainda aposto hoje ou
não eu vou pensar o pessoal mexe é
espero que vocês gostem quanto você
possui um like favorito fiquem bem e até
a moda foco em posse né
[Música]
é
o